lvmh qui s'offrent les services de
renseignement de l'état pour infiltrer
le journal indépendant et engagé fakir
c'est à la fois impressionnant et
burlesque
qu'est ce que le premier groupe de luxe
au monde dont la capitalisation s'élève
à 212 milliards d'euros vient chercher
en infiltrant un journal quasi locales
dont la porte est militante ne
s'aventurent pas au delà d'une
dénonciation satirique des inégalités du
capitalisme outrancier dont souffrent
les travailleurs précaires et bien il
semblerait que ce soit avant tout pour
une question d'image
bah oui mars 2013 les petites actions
militantes des sympathisants de fakir et
son rédacteur en chef françois ruffin
aujourd'hui député la france insoumise
viennent troubler la sérénité de bernard
arnault patron de lvmh et accessoirement
un des hommes les plus riches au monde
lvmh demande donc à bernard squarcini ex
patron de la dst et de la des séries
jusqu'en 2012 sous sarkozy
reconverti dans le privé et employés
depuis peu par le groupe de s'occuper de
ces fauteurs de troubles en effet une
enquête de mediapart révèle l'espionnage
à grande échelle de fakir par des
branches des services secrets français
et démontre que ce sont surtout les
côtés parasites et fauteurs de troubles
qui dérange bernard arnault et son bras
droit de l'époque pierre godé pourtant
c'est baba cool si tu as liste comme se
plaît à les appeler bernard squarcini
désormais aux commandes de l'opération
d'infiltration ne sont vraiment pas
grand chose face à lvmh
qu'est-ce qu'ils font concrètement ils
organisent les mini opérations de
sabotage par exemple courant mars 2013
en se présentant devant les bureaux du
groupe à bruxelles puis à paris et en
s'affichant avec des tee-shirts floqués
d'un satirique ilove bernard en scandant
des slogans de toutes sortes contre lvmh
le but ultime est qu'un groupe de
personnes parviennent à s'introduire
légalement à une assemblée générale des
actionnaires de lvmh à paris en avril
2013 pourri je cite mettre le bazar
après avoir acheté des actions comme
ticket d'entrée pas grand chose donc
pour être en croire ce pas vraiment ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier de tentative
d'attentât eh bien figurez-vous que pour
lvmh c'est très très sérieux
je saisis l'ancien du service et surtout
la préfecture de police et la direction
de la sécurité publique
ça peut être intéressant aussi
puisqu'ils font du racolage de les
infiltrer non oui c'est ce que je
regrette toujours conservé voit la super
bon de chez les babas cool
situationniste et où on peut encore
sortir du monde sur paris s'est s'appuyé
à la presse quoi je vais voir ça de la
balle molle que le chef que j'ai
auditionné hier le numéro 2 de lvmh
pierre godé continuent de s'inquiéter de
plus en plus en fin d'après-midi s'est
présenté toute une équipe d'énergumènes
à nos bureaux de bruxelles
ces joyeux drilles arboraient des
tee-shirts à et lov bernard yahvé rufin
le gars qui dirige fakir
je ne sais pas si on peut obtenir le
concours des services de police belges
le voir ce qu'on peut faire on peut
introduire quelqu'un et qu'ils font un
appel au peuple un oui j'ai vu c'est
sous le manteau attention avec des trucs
aux dés et tout c'est pas de public
c'est à travers une liste adresse mail
et de points de contact déjà pré établis
donc les gens se connaissent d'avant on
peut dire c'est bien ça le problème
traduction de l' échange fakir n'a pas
fait un post facebook invitant ses
sympathisants à bazarder lvmh
il s'agit d' échanges privés que square
signé à intercepter en fouillant les
messages des personnels des personnes
concernées et ça c'est illégal
alors que l'assemblée générale d'avril
2013 approche à grands pas la secrétaire
personnelle de bernard arnault fait
savoir à square ceni que le patron de
lvmh est très stressé par cette histoire
de fauteurs de troubles
d'autant qu'un groupe de joyeux drilles
est parvenu à pénétrer dans les locaux
de lvmh avenue montaigne et il ya
surpris bernard arnault en personne dans
le hall d'entrée en compagnie du
banquier david de rothschild françois
ruffin le raconte lui même sur son site
internet
on arrive à l'accueil et là comme par
hasard il y à bernard arnault
alors moi éperdument amoureux comme je
l'étais à l'époque un peu déçu depuis je
crie bernard bernard bernard rattrapé
par le vigile qui me met sous le bras
comme ça j'arrive encore à lui tendre un
mug et bernard arnault se retrouve avec
un mug ilove bernard dans les mains
c'est l'attentât que nous avions produit
il faut dire que le milliardaire a
visiblement eu très très peur
l'épisode le plus comique je pense c'est
quand la secrétaire de bernard arnault
appel bernard squarcini et lui dit oh là
là on est effrayé parce qu'il ya trois
membres de fakhir qui sont entrés dans
notre immeuble rue
montaigne et bernard arnault qui
d'habitude ne descend jamais justement
il était en bas ils ont crié il était
avec david de rothschild donc ils ont
tous eu peur
et puis vous imaginez david de
rothschild il va aller raconter ça à
droite à gauche
donc ça va pas du tout est ce que vous
pourriez nous installer un bouton anti
panique
parallèlement bernard squarcini a
délégué une partie de l'opération rufin
à un cabinet de renseignement privé
dirigé par un ex policier de la brigade
financière de l'antiterrorisme un
certain hervé séveno qu'il a facturé 30
8500 euros
inutile de préciser que le sabotage de
l'ag d'avril n'a pas pu avoir lieu
puisque bernard squarcini et son équipe
d'espions ont tout mis en oeuvre pour en
empêcher la tenue à la plus grande
satisfaction de bernard arnault morale
de l'histoire si tenté qu'il y en ait
une
une petite action symbolique parodique
même d'un petit groupe d'individus
motivé parvient à mettre en branle bas
de combat une multinationale qui
effrayait par des babas cool joue de ses
plus précieux contacts au sein de l'état
pour éviter un esclandre
c'est quand même incroyable n'est ce pas
monsieur rufin inquiétant là dedans
c'est comment l'état se met au service
de lvmh le disait déjà mais c'est
vraiment la fusion entre les grandes
fortunes et et l'état en effet on peut
dire qu'il ya de quoi se poser des
questions et pas les plus valorisants
pour l'hexagone
contacté par rt france lvmh n'a pour le
moment pas donné suite à nos questions
sur le sujet
quant à bernard squarcini voici ce qu'il
a déclaré à la chaîne singer view et
vous savez quand vous avez des gens qui
veulent s'introduire dans des assemblées
générales pour les perturber et empêcher
qu'elle se déroule alors que ces deux
droits et ce constat du si et où vous
mettez en place un dispositif pour
empêcher les intrusions des phases comme
casino carrefour et autres et vous avez
des gens qui au tour de monsieur
françois ruffin nous ont informés
volontairement
quand je vois pas du tout une infraction